on ferme la porte à 10% est-ce que tu
m'entends depuis six mois
trois années dont la mère de jocelyne
côté qu' à 94 ans dorment dans ce
sous-sol avec comme seul mur de simple
rideau
si tu veux jose avec maman privé et ben
faut que ce mari viennent par les eaux
ce soit au coucher ou sur paul v ils
sont 80 à attendre à court ou moyen
terme une chambre avec de vrais mur à la
maison des années mais il n'y a que 20
places
pourtant un projet d'agrandissement a
été accepté dans le cadre du programme
accès logis mais il est en veilleuse
depuis quelques années déjà pour qu'il
se réalise la communauté devrait en
financer le quart soit 700 mille dollars
ce que déplore le maire de grande-vallée
c'est impensable de dire capable de
raconter sa maîtresse des lieux le faux
billets sont les municipalités du
secteur réclament du gouvernement
couillard qu'il rehausse l'aide
financière versée aux régions éloignées
mise à mal par les compressions en début
de mandat nous les mères de les faire de
ce que je peux vous dire là tu fais que
on dit que ce dossier qui doit
absolument goûter pour l'autre pôle
morpho là dessus c'est très clair selon
l'association qui représente les groupes
en logements collectifs au québec dix
mille unités tarder à être construite
parce que la contribution demandée au
milieu est trop élevé calmont au regard
de la politique
les grosses compagnies comme bombardier
ne le finance les choses mais
l'hébergement marcel l'ami elle a eu la
chance d'avoir sa place à la maison des
aînés il y a quatre ans elle compatit
avec ses nombreux amis qui ont dû
quitter le village à contrecoeur moins
fort d'issy la rive marot chaque autre
chute car garé au coin au lavoir 18 %
des québécois de 75 ans et plus vivent
en résidence
c'est plus du double de la moyenne
canadienne à
le vieillissement de la population des
situations comme celle de grande valley
pourraient devenir beaucoup plus
fréquentes
en attendant sa chambre madame le brune
ne se plaint pas et demeure positive
c'est tout naturel pour cette mère de
dix sept enfants c'est dans un champ
sa frappe est plus commode de faire
parler ses très bonnes mains ici michel
félix tremblay radio-canada à grande
vallée